if you were trapped on an island full of
flesh-eating monsters what would you do
you'll need to team up with terrifying
animals bloodthirsty mercenaries and one
true Island God in order to escape and
get home alive I'm going to break down
the mistakes made what you should do and
how to beat the hollow Earth monsters in
Skull Island these explorers will be
forced to battle underground monsters
and almost all of them will die Charlie
here is busy helping his researcher dad
explore the depths of the dark ocean he
secretly wants to quit the family
business and go live a normal life at
college so he talks to him about it but
his dad tells him that they're gonna
talk about it later because he wants to
focus on the bombs right now in order to
map out the ocean floor not realizing
that these bombs will awaken something
horrifying Beneath the Sea and just then
Charlie Sees someone floating near their
boat right near the active boss he yells
at his team to stop and jumps in to
rescue her bringing her back up but
something is very wrong she wakes up and
desperately asks them where is her dog
but these people have no idea what she
is talking about and the crew
investigates who this woman is and pour
her a cup of coffee but she doesn't know
what coffee is Charlie tries to radio
for help but this woman begs him to not
call anyone because someone terrifying
will find them and the crew tries to
reassure her that they're the good guys
Charlie's dad even introduces himself as
cap what a lame name and also so does
Charlie's best friend here named Mike
she tells them that she escaped a ship
because the sky was on fire confusing
the crap out of everybody but then they
see a flare light up in the sky in the
distance and rush over to check it out
the girl yells at them to not go see it
but cap reassures her that everything
will be fine she asks Charlie how many
guns do they have because they need to
get ready for war but he says well that
sucks they have none outside the crew
sees a boat approaching but find it
really weird because nobody's radio
contacted anybody just then the boat
disappears with storm back in the
captain's deck Charlie tries to get to
know his new friend and he manages to
scrape up enough machismo to find out
that her name is Annie and he tells her
that they are mapping out the ocean
floor which is really cool because they
get to set off deep sea bombs but that's
when Annie's face turns white at the
sound of what he just said she tells him
that they need to stop the bombs because
they'll awaken the monster that stranded
her here in the first place still very
confused he runs to go tell his dad what
his new cute friend has just said and
nobody notices the two assassins have
just snuck onto the boat Charlie tells
his dad what Annie said but he just goes
ah and laughs it off but that's when
loud bangs are heard coming from the
cockpit forcing everyone to follow this
wild goose chase inside they are stunned
to see Annie having just taken out an
assassin and also declares that she has
just destroyed their radio she tells
them that she is not going back on the
boat that she came from and by now at
this point everybody is just gone you
know what alright enough of this we we
want to know what the frick destroyed
her boat and why are you so freaking
scared lady that's what they ask her and
right then an assassin wakes up and
quickly pulls out his Knight at the
Second Assassin about to pounce gets
silently dragged off the boat by what
looks like a giant tentacle back on the
deck the Assassin tells Charlie's crew
that if they keep looking for creatures
under the sea they're going to wind up
dead unless they head back to this ship
but that's when this tentacle slabs one
of the captain's crew members onto the
window and whips him back out to the Sea
as his screams disappear in the distance
Annie yells that they need to get off of
this boat now and everybody runs outside
but that's when Mike's dad gets crushed
by giant tentacles the crew stops and
stares in shock then Mike taste tests
something that he never wished he had
and just then the boat begins to
violently shake and one by one more
tentacles rise from the dark Seas and by
now at this point complete chaos has
taken over the ship explosions go off
and cap watches all of his crew members
quickly die horrible deaths Annie gets
her handcuffs off and yells at everybody
to get to the island and jumps into the
water the group gets separated and the
ship quickly plunges down into the sea
dragged into the water terrified and
Confused cap comes face to face with the
mythical monster looking into its Soul
he fails to comprehend the horrors that
his family is about to experience
struggling for breath he tries to escape
but that's when Annie shows up and saves
him and some of the survivors return to
the surface nearby washing ashore on
this Mysterious Island Charlie and Mike
realized that they've become separated
from the other survivors alone afraid
and without their parents they try to
figure out their next moves okay we can
find our parents and also our best
friend just lost his own dad that is why
in order to survive obviously we need
shelter we need food and we need water
but if we can't find water we might have
to drink our friend's coffee-filled Pete
let me explain the crew did everything
wrong from start to finish why are they
using bombs to map the ocean floor
there's more modern ways to know I don't
know more subtle ways to do this you can
use sonar what a concept that is you can
use stereo cameras you can use strobe
lights as a means to create a 3D mapping
of the ocean floor in that area they
didn't have any of that stuff which
makes everything about this whole
operation super suspicious because then
that tells me this crew either are
idiots but on top of that we got a
freaking tentacle monster yanking the
boat down into the water we're totally
screwed so aside from that cluster of a
situation we are now stranded on an
unknown Island we know nothing about so
we're not out of the woods just yet
because as I said at the beginning we
gotta find food shelter and water but
there's no guarantee that there is fresh
water on this island and in fact islands
are usually characterized by their
limited supply of fresh water some
people have only been able to survive on
Islands by developing their own rain
water collection system it's really
complex and there's usually a lot of
trial and error if we cannot find water
anywhere and we can't collect it fast
enough we might have to drink our
friend's coffee-filled pea look if I was
Charlie my friends Mike's dad was known
as the coffee master and because of this
it's likely that his son drank a lot of
coffee which means he's gonna pee a lot
faster than I would which means I might
have to drink his his urine in order for
me to be able to survive the next
morning Mike notices an injury on his
chest from the disaster last night but
he thinks eh it's no big deal and
doesn't say anything what an idiot and
just then a ferocious crab comes out
from the sand and attacks him pulling
him away to consume his flesh but
Charlie saves him in the nick of time
the two barely escape with their lives
thinking it's over but then they realize
that this entire Beach is infested with
these monsters they try to head towards
this rock the only hard surfs around and
get on top of it and then they see the
crabs disappear but now they realize
they're trapped on here as well Mike
quickly has an idea and they throw this
weird Rock Bug into the distance and the
crabs swarm it and Charlie and Mike make
a run for it however though this one
crab spots them and guns for their flesh
about to sink its teeth into them but
then they get saved by none other than
Annie she orders them to work together
as they take down a few more monsters
and then Charlie and Mike run like hell
towards Annie since Annie found this
spear Mike now thinks that there are
other humans living on this island and
they don't notice another crap tracking
them and gets ready to attack but then a
giant Roar across the island stop
everybody in their tracks the fear in
the air is poppable it causes all of
these monsters to retreat into this sand
and Annie looks at them in disbelief and
tells them she doesn't know what they
just heard which means they must be on
alert not trusting her fully Micah
questions her some more and finds out
that she actually came from a different
Island before she was kidnapped she's
never been here before and has no clue
where they are knowing what this means
Mike begins to sweat and tells Charlie
that because of everything that has
happened he thinks he knows where they
really are Skull Island and that's when
Mike spills the beans what he really
knows before they left the sea Mike and
his father brought an old map of this
island from an old GI Soldier which
means this must be where they are
because this isn't any ordinary Island
he begged Charlie to forgive him but
then they suddenly get stopped by these
lost soldiers and then realize that oh
when did you know Annie has now
disappeared elsewhere Charlie's father
cap wakes up on a different side of this
island and quickly begins searching for
his son he soon find smoke in the
distance and heads towards it but then
he hears something following him turning
around the rock opens up and reveals the
most beautiful crystals that he's ever
seen mesmerizing him right as a Sinister
creature's face appears from within the
Rock and approaches him but suddenly
gets shot by the soldier angering the
bug and it charges at him to kill him
Captain snaps out of it and sees this
strange woman here freaking out and
running away he quickly catches up with
her and finds out that her name is Irene
and she's as lost as he is she got
Shipwrecked earlier while on a cruise
ship and is now stranded and just then
they hear a loud roar in the distance
sending shivers down their spine and cap
tells her that they need to move
continuing to the location of the smoke
they spot a bunch of soldiers in the
distance but something is off cap then
reveals to Irene that he knows she is
full of [__] these men are her men and
she can't fool him and he confesses that
he doesn't want any trouble he only
wants to find his son and he'll help her
look for what he thinks she wants that
girl that came on his ship Annie back at
Charlie's location these men hold these
kids up at gunpoint they say they're
looking for a young girl but Charlie
asks them if they've ever seen his death
the conversation is cut short as any
surprise attacks them and they try to
reach for their weapons and that was
their biggest mistake because then they
see something charging at them weighing
probably over ten thousand pounds and
it's coming right at them and he smiles
though and these two boys look on in
shock as this new monster busts in grabs
Annie's arm and flings her away in the
distance thinking she's now dead Charlie
and Mike start running in the opposite
direction but soon get tackled by this
confused looking Soldier hearing
terrifying incoming noises they hide in
these bushes and the soldiers pissing
his pants he tells them that this
monster has already killed six of his
best men and Charlie gets mad and asks
why the hell did they bring the monster
that they just saw to this island but
the soldier says that they didn't he
reveals that it has been following Annie
since they took her and it must have
swam all the way to her here on this
island Mike thinks that the monster ate
her and that she's dead but oh doesn't
he wish the soldier says and that's when
Charlie realizes that the monster that
they are hiding from his Annie's pet
they then hear a rumbling of noises
coming at them the soldier makes a run
for it and the boys chase after him
approaching this mud pit he suddenly
gets eaten by a crocodile and more
starts swarming them Mike panics and
says not to move a muscle as they get
closer to their death and this one
stands up but they quickly realize that
this isn't an ordinary crocodile backing
up slowly they Sprint for their lives
jumping into this water while these
creatures try to catch them with their
teeth oh my gosh okay let's think about
it where two teenagers run an island
that we've never seen before you've now
seen a giant monster dog thing that's
freaking huge it's eaten six people oh
and by the way there's a giant squid
thing in the ocean and on top of that
there's a freaking Roar that shook the
entire Island we are so screwed now we
gotta deal with this giant prehistoric
looking alligator crocodile thing so
here's how we're gonna get out of it I'm
gonna have this giant prehistoric
looking Gator thing play a game of tag
Let Me Explain If this giant crocodile
bites me we're dead we are so toast and
you want to know why because a regular
alligator has a massive bite force and
then it could easily stop drop and roll
and twist and rip my arm off yeah sounds
like a bad day and this thing is bigger
than a normal crocodile or alligator and
according to scientists agent alligators
or crocodiles they had a bite force of
over 18
000 pounds which is more than the T-Rex
which has 12 000 pounds but I gotta tell
you my weebs they did everything wrong
from start to finish first they should
have picked a different career choice
and have not gone on that boat and two
don't jump in the freaking water
crocodiles can swim and fun fact the
modern crocodile can actually go pretty
quick on land but they can go even three
times faster in the water the best move
that we could have made instead would
have been to run back the way we came
here or at least in any direction away
from this freaking river that you see
right here because where there's one
mature Croc there's usually another 20
since they live in groups and also
running away in a straight line is a
terrible idea you gotta go zigzag you
gotta change your direction on the
regular because like I said the modern
crocodile is pretty quick on land too
but if it comes down to it we can always
let Mike take the fall and be our meat
Shield sorry Mike struggling for breath
the monsters tried to pick at their
flesh but then suddenly run away Mike
says to thank the Lord they must be safe
but Charlie realizes that they're headed
straight down waterfall and they
realized it's too late going over the
edge they plunged deep into the dark
cold water but come out alive finally
free they happily let down their guard
and that was their biggest mistake
because then a giant crocodile Swan dies
from over the falls down towards them
and disappears into the water near them
forcing them to swim like hell gaining
on the monster is about to rip into
their flesh but then it gets picked up
by the king of the island of monsters
King Kong he casually walks past the
boys and ignores them while they watch
in all that's when the creature from
earlier Pops in front of them with Annie
scaring these two but she casually says
yeah that's the big monkey elsewhere cap
see some injured soldiers returning to
Irene's Camp they report that they ran
into some boys that went this way
annoyed this guy jokes that he's gonna
kill Annie but Irene looks at him dead
in the face and makes him remember his
mission to bring her back alive this man
updates them that their rescue chopper
will arrive soon and with it they'll be
able to take down this Beast that is
with Annie and finally escape this
hellhole Irene says that they put a
tracker in her handcuffs and asks if cap
knows about this place since he's an
Explorer he says based on his expertise
he thinks there's a magical Fountain
located somewhere on this island which
is way more believable now considering
all the strange things that they've seen
since they've got here cap also asks
what she wants with Annie she tells him
that they didn't kidnap her but they
found her 20 miles away from here on
another Island there they found her all
alone and was living with that monster
they both were incredibly violent then
they come across the sea of flowers but
notice that the field has been destroyed
by a massive force of wind from
something and then a piercing Screech is
heard in the distance and this giant
Firebird descends from the cover of
clouds to kill them all kidnapping this
one soldier and it tries to get away not
letting any danger stop them and with
the coast clear they press on and this
Soldier says that she's finally fixed
Annie's tracker which means they can now
hunt her down reaching the sea they
finally make contact with their incoming
helicopter and think they'll finally be
saved but that's when their hopes are
quickly extinguished the scene near them
starts rumbling and this giant tentacle
shoots out from below and grabs the
helicopter right from the Sky I begin
apart and killing everyone on it in less
than five seconds all the while as the
group on the beach watches in terrifying
disbelief everyone quickly realizes how
trapped they really are without a
helicopter though she comes up with a
new plan to get Irene and she asks cap
what he thinks about the bird that they
just saw and he tells her that he thinks
the bird came down from a nest but then
flew to a second Nest since it headed in
the opposite direction that it came from
this solidifies Irene's Theory and she
announces her new plan to catch Annie
and separate her from the monster she is
with they will lure Annie and the
monster here and bathe the firebird into
helping them out once they have Annie
they will finally be able to leave here
but knowing what's waiting for them in
the ocean cap asks hiring how will they
escape through the water she tells him
that she hasn't figured out that part
yet but for now they should just focus
on retrieving Annie meanwhile the boys
continue to follow Annie through the
jungle and Charlie tries to find out how
much Mike knows about the island but he
says that the olgi revealed to him that
other Boats were hired to find this
island as well because of its location
it doesn't show up on any radar it means
that it can only be found in person but
Mike says that he doesn't know why
they're looking for the island in the
first place and he stupidly never asked
his dad about it either okay here's a
crazy thought they could have figured
out everything from the moment that old
GI told us what he did because look the
clues were all there and I mean
everything let me explain first off Mike
and his dead dad were so stupid to not
tell their crew but the old GI told them
because with a little bit of deductive
reasoning we could have easily figured
out that this island didn't make any
sense from the jumper stop it was either
fake or the most dangerous thing on the
planet why would it not show up on radar
this island shouldn't exist and the
problem is what we know about science is
really really little we've only
discovered about five percent of the
secrets of the universe that mean 95 of
it we don't know crap about so maybe you
think it's possible to find a freaky
Island yeah it's entirely possible and
also fun fact over 65 of our planet
remains unexplored most of which it Lies
Beneath the ocean so for context check
this out according to NASA it's easier
to put a person in space than it is to
send a person to the bottom of the ocean
why the pressure the pressure exerted by
the water above is equivalent for one
person to try and support 50 jumbo Jets
and while we know a lot of what's
beneath the earth's surface most of
which we've never actually explored
we've actually never been anywhere near
the Earth's core due to the level of
heat pressure and radioactivity and this
means that everything we know we really
don't know a hundred percent so in short
my weebs this island is super weird
there's not many of them there's just
one freaking big one kind of makes me
think that this island is not safe and
we should never have gone on it in the
first place all the signs were there and
we chose to go to it anyways they are
idiots the kids take a break from
walking Charlie then goes to talk to
Annie but finds out her dog's name is
Dog Annie reveals to him that the bad
guys are after her but she doesn't know
why they invaded her home and started
shooting at her dog and the next thing
she knew she woke up and she was in
handcuffs she doesn't know how long
she's been on her Island for and doesn't
even know her age she reveals that she
hoped his dad escape the boat earlier
and that he is on the island too
shocking Charlie and he notices
something even more shocking in the
distance King Kong hungry and he
announces that they're going to get
breakfast Charlie then wakes up Mike but
then he realizes that his wound on his
chest is starting to get worse looking
for food Mike and Charlie spot this
strange looking bird it approaches them
fast and he gets ready to kill them but
that's when Annie and dog show up again
and Slaughter the bird telling them that
they've caught breakfast while eating
they find out how Annie and dog met she
says their dads killed each other when
she was younger leaving her and dog all
alone they joined forces then and then
took over the island that she came from
finishing up to carry on and discuss how
they'll leave the island it's not going
to be easy they can't build a raft
because of the terrifying creatures in
the sea but that's when Mike realizes
that the guys chasing them must have
radios if they could steal it they could
maybe call a plane but their
conversation is cut short when Mike
realizes that someone is missing hearing
sounds from this dark hole nearby they
go to check it out and hear his screams
they find out that Charlie has fallen
down deep into this cave realize amazing
where he is and he tells Mike the worst
news of all he's fallen into a flesh
eating bug's home Mike tells Annie to
make her dog get Charlie but the dog
doesn't want to because he only cares
about Annie Mike tries to convince the
dog but it walks away causing him to get
mad that Annie isn't helping Charlie
even though he saved her earlier so what
does he do he points out the obvious and
he tells Annie that you're a bad friend
and that pisses her off and says she's a
great friend meanwhile Down in the Hole
Charlie pulls out something and
discovers an old sword Mike then
suddenly jumps down and says that hey
he's here to save him because Annie's
dog is useless more rumbling is then
heard outside as the giant ape crosses
over their path pulling out this tree
from the ground and shaking the entire
Earth with the terrifying show over
Charlie tries to focus on getting out
Mike grabs his chest and secretly
wheezes in pain but tries to hide his
suffering from Charlie that's when this
skeleton starts moving causing Mike to
run behind Charlie and they prepare for
what's to come but that's when Annie
quickly swings down into the hole to
join them she and Mike get into a cute
argument about their hand size about who
is stronger and they get confronted by
the monster that lives there approaching
them drooling in hunger Charlie tries to
attack it but his sword breaks and out
of options him and Mike prepare to kick
the bucket and he smiles and then
announces that she will perform a magic
trick for them approaching the monster
she collapses in front of it and begins
crying out for help like a little baby
the two boys watch and stared confused
as ever and she tells him that the fun
is about to begin and then right on cue
bursting into the cave from up above dog
sees Annie in trouble and comes charging
down like the White Knight that he is to
save her elsewhere this Soldier asks cap
why he got into the exploring business
and he tells him that one time he saw
something magical in the ocean twice the
size of any boat he's ever seen and made
up of the most beautiful colors he could
ever imagine since that day he made it
his mission to find those creatures and
prove that they exist on Earth he claims
that there are mysteries on Earth that
science cannot explain but they do exist
and one of them is the legend of the
Fountain of you he thinks this island is
connected to it and that this place
might be a Gateway into a hollow Earth
an earth inside of the earth that we
know and this is where all these strange
creatures have come from and then caps
which is the questioning and tries to
figure out more about Irene she says
she's a botanist but that she's not here
for plants just then the soldiers get
radioed in that everybody is in position
to capture Annie Irene reveals that she
thinks Cap's kids are with Annie and
then Irene sees kept giving her a look
about all the weapons and she tells him
that if she's not careful Annie's dog
will kill more of her men than it
already has and everybody waits back at
Charlie's location the three continue to
bond over cute crap that I'm not going
to talk about and that's when Annie's
dog senses something in the distance and
starts growling realizing who it is and
he says people with guns are headed
their way and she shows them the bullet
wound on dog and tells them that these
people tried to kill her pet because of
this she will find the woman who did
this and take her down and so she
quickly gets ready for battle not
realizing that something even more
terrifying than the soldiers is watching
them she tells Charlie and Mike to wait
in these bushes while she handles
business because apparently Mike and
Charlie are weak little wusses Charlie
then finally notices that something is
wrong with Mike because he's burning up
and she charges over them into the field
of battle not realizing that she's just
fallen into the Soldier's track and
quickly gets surrounded and shot in the
neck with a sleeping Dart noticing Annie
in trouble dog starts chasing right at
them to save Annie but Irene tells the
men to not shoot it but to just wait the
dog gets closer and closer and the
soldiers start to get nervous but just
then the firebird snatches the dog
mid-air blowing everybody away violently
to then see the bird taking the hubless
dog back to its nest meanwhile in the
bushes Charlie spots his dad within the
group of soldiers and thinks that he
must be held hostage feeling guilty for
all of this being his fault Mike tells
Charlie to find a way to help his dad
and he stands up from cover and gets
spotted by the tense soldiers he walks
out to say hi to Charlie's dad giving
him a hug and secretly Whispering that
Charlie is safe but then says out loud
that he doesn't know where Charlie is
and then he notices Irene and the two
stare confusingly like they know each
other hearing the discreet of the bird
in the distance Irene quickly tells
everybody to go back to their base camp
for the night carrying with them of
sleeping Annie but all the while Charlie
watches everything from the distance
okay yeah I know this was a [__] show to
begin with but let's get that out of the
way we're going to need to take a step
back way up in the sky and look at
everything from a good bird's eye view
because I can't hold it back any longer
because why is everybody keeping secrets
Mike's dad cap Irene what is with all
the secrets you don't need to Mike
should have shared that hey I'm hurt
this is a problem it's getting worse
what was he due he tells nobody there's
literally no reason why he should not
have told us and he didn't even pretend
to work with these two or get their
Insight on things if I was Charlie I at
the very least would have made her
realize that taking on highly trained
armed Soldiers with a simple pet is
probably the stupidest thing you could
possibly do yes her stupid pet is huge
it's monstrous it's impressive but they
got guns and modern technology they
could have something with big enough
Firepower to take it down look at this
it's fairly obvious in an open field
what they were trying to do since they
had guns it would have been obvious for
this terrain to favor the soldiers and
since we knew that these soldiers were
after Annie we could have lured them
away to somewhere else where Annie had a
better situation because the area that
would have helped Annie and her dog the
best would have been close quarter
terrain within the jungle or Mountain
areas because no matter how strong Annie
thinks her dog is one against 20 guys
with guns was stupid as hell Charlie
thinks of his next move but that's when
he hears a noise and something
approaching him he bolts right fast as
hell and he runs through the same open
field from before that was his biggest
mistake a Firebird grabs him out of
nowhere and takes him high up into the
sky dropping him down into this unknown
location quickly getting his
surroundings he realizes that he's been
trapped thousands of feet in the air in
this creepy Temple back of the camp cap
watches over Annie but sees Mike and
Irene talking suspiciously Mike then
enters the tent and confronts Charlie's
dad about where Charlie really is he
whispers to him that he thought cap was
a hostage and that's why Charlie is
hiding waiting for the right time to
save them Mike then starts to lose it
again and complains that he now has a
splitting head headache and is at the
end of his rope and he confesses to cap
that this expedition was actually funded
by Irene's team in secret they knew he
didn't like private money but this was
the only way to fund his dreams of
exploring the deep ocean cab then like a
good mature man moves past this
information and tells Mike despite his
dad's death he will always have a home
with them that's so nice but then he
notices Mike's Vision going bad and
makes a joke before returning to the
main topic Mike tells him that another
ship she hired earlier found the island
that animals on one month back and that
they sent its location before they
disappeared Mike also asked cap if he's
seen the giant monkey walking around the
island but the captain says he has no
idea what he's talking about back at
Charlie's position he hears more
Sinister sounds approaching him he gets
ready to run away for the 12th time but
then discovers Annie's dog is there with
him angry and Afraid dog growls at him
but Charlie tries to calm it down
realizing he's out of options he begins
to get desperate and starts talking to
himself finding out that the dog
recognizes Annie's name when he says it
and he gets an idea and he tries to
communicate with the dog to get him out
of here by acting out what he wants him
to do he pretends to climb down this
giant Temple and dog finally recognizes
what Charlie's trying to do and copies
his actions seeing this Charlie quickly
runs to get on the dog and the two get
ready to work together to escape but
that's when they notice the temple
artwork on the walls in front of them
but that's when they hear sounds
approaching them and they finally see
the king of the island closer than
they've ever seen him before the entire
area shakes and the vibrations make dog
lose his grip sending the two to fall
down the wall fast barely Landing
somehow without a scratch or any broken
bones Charlie tries to take a sneak peek
of the gorilla but notices him playing
with a necklace on the wall and looking
sad he then goes to meet dog and the two
get to work to getting back to Annie
alive back at Camp Irene goes to check
on Annie and makes comments about how
bad Mike is starting to look and then
she reveals that she knows cap sung
Charlie is somewhere nearby and he
confesses that he would likely try to
sneak into this camp at some point Irene
then rolls her eyes and says she'll tell
her man not to shoot him a violent
whistle is then heard up high in the sky
and cause everybody to go check it out
and that's when they see it a whale
flying but it's dead and its giant
structure majestically sourced past them
Charlie and dog also see the confusion
in the sky and see it crash down right
in front of the gorilla causing this
Beast to go mad as hell because he's
been summoned for a fight he goes and
Roars in the distance and Roars directly
at the ocean front The Sounds cause dog
to get agitated and leave the area with
Charlie following behind soon they reach
the camp and Charlie tries to figure out
a plan with a dog to rescue his friends
meanwhile down in the camp Mike
collapses to the ground and the group
sees his body covered in strange veins
Annie then also finally wakes up and is
mad as hell and mentions to everybody
here that they will all die Irene
arrives and tries to calm her down and
explain her actions but sees how Mike is
concerned Irene asks Annie if something
bit Mike and she says that he was
electrocuted in the ocean by a
mysterious monster Irene then rushes
over to go see cap and tell him the news
while Annie tries to help him but that's
when she realizes that her dog isn't
here and looks directly at Irene for and
but that's when she tells Annie the
worst news of all seeing the pain in
Annie's eyes Irene confesses to Annie
that she was just trying to separate the
two so she could talk to her without
anyone being killed she asks Annie what
happened to her father but finds out
that he died trying to protect her but
they got stranded on the island Irene
tries to stay grounded at this
heartbreaking news and Annie starts
complaining about some random kid stuff
and getting on Irene's nerves and then
can politely suggest that they do get
out outside in a friendly deathmatch and
he agrees Annie then stretches and
prepares to beat her face in but notices
Irene's face goes set she claims that
she buried Annie years ago but then she
got word that someone found her
shipwreck years later she tried to reach
that ship before it went missing and
then Annie starts to quickly catch on to
what Irene is saying she's saying that
she is Annie's mother but she doesn't
remember her face at all and Annie says
she can't be her mom because she's a
horrible person because her man attacked
her dog and anybody that attacks a
girl's dog is a bad person and this
forces Irene to go and try to explain
herself okay this is wild and how bad
this writing is Holy Smokes it's making
my brain hurt no one here including
Irene and cab are acting like proper
human parents if I was the mom I would
have avoided whole this situation and
could have still found Annie by just
writing her a cute little letter covered
in my scent let me explain the mom tried
to rescue Annie and ended up running
into this monster when they didn't know
it was Annie's pet so they tried to
shoot it and it ran away but here's the
thing they were so done with how they
acted because this whole goose chase was
unnecessary they didn't have to have a
freaking Firebird as the means to get
the dog away from Annie there are easier
ways to reach out to Annie and Irene the
ma should have known this it's noted
that Annie lost contact with her mother
when she was about five years old due to
Childhood Amnesia and this is an age
period that is common for children to
rapidly begin forgetting memories of her
life in her earlier years as a child
gets older because if I was Irene AKA an
attractive single mom I could have
assumed she definitely wouldn't have
remembered me if we got separated when
she was five and she suffered a
traumatic experience when that happened
even if we didn't know that our baby
daddy died a horrible death in front of
Annie's eyes getting lost in a
terrifying shipwreck on a deserted
island for a little while with sir only
be long enough to have her memory have
some gaps in short we could have assumed
it's likely that Annie could have grown
up as a feral child and that is when a
child grows up separated from Human
contact and acts basically like an
animal and has zero social behavior and
that is why I would have stayed hidden
and would have waited and watched Annie
for a day or two before sneaking into
her home during a time period that when
she went out to hunt and then using our
family's photos I would have left them
all over the ship along with a note and
then it would have covered all these
items into perfume cenovars because all
of this stuff might trigger something in
Annie's memory and also her oil factory
senses which increases our chances of
any one of these smells triggering a
memory within Annie causing her to
remember me and then I would slowly and
gradually expose myself to Annie not all
at once not with guns and certainly not
using a giant freaking Firebird to try
to separate her from her dog that she
clearly is attached to Meanwhile Charlie
lays out his plan to rescue his friends
with the dog he tells them that they'll
set this tree on fire as a distraction
while they run to the other side of the
camp then once those soldiers come to
check it out he'll sneak in and save his
friends and his dad so they get to work
he then sets this tree on fire and
thinks everything is gonna go smoothly
because these two quickly realize that
this isn't a tree it's a monster's Nest
they quickly wake up and begin swarming
Charlie and the dog the giant Flames
caused the soldiers to spot it and
Charlie the news quickly reaches the
camp and Annie busts out heading
straight to her pet howling at the dog
the dog howls back and runs to her and
she quickly gets cornered by these
flesh-eating monsters dog quickly saves
her at the last minute while the
soldiers managed to stop the rest of
these creatures in cap then rushes to
Charlie the dog quickly turns Fierce and
attacks Irene but she tells the soldiers
to not shoot it still mad and he tells
her that she needs to apologize for
hurting dog in these three makeup
Charlie then goes to check on Mike and
finds out that he's recovering and
everybody thinks things are starting to
look up but that's when terrifying
screams are heard outside and they
stumble upon these giant tentacles
crawling the camp and they quickly pull
the remaining soldiers away into the
dark ocean Irene says that she's had
enough of this stupid squid and they
need to kill it in order to escape and
that's when Charlie has the wildest idea
ever he says that they'll use the giant
ape to kill it he tells the gang that he
saw the ape playing with the necklace
earlier and thinks this necklace has
some important meaning to it this is why
they should try to steal it and make
this 40 000 ton monster chase them
because that's a brilliant plan why
because they'll be able to lead him
directly to the script but everybody
looks at him like he's crazy because he
is Charlie tells them that he saw
artwork of Kong fighting monsters on the
temple walls which means this must be
his job both creatures are too smart to
go near each other which means luring
the monster into the water is their only
shot and they're running out of time to
save Mike reluctantly everyone agrees to
this crazy plan lure Kong into the water
and fire off the flare when they do
Charlie gets on to dog and Annie tells
him to hold on to her and he gets a
little bit too excited and they head off
reaching the gorilla's Temple they
approach it cautiously Charlie mentions
that his dad thinks there's a whole
world below this one but Annie says that
she can't go down there or else she'll
get sick suspicious Charlie asks uh what
do you mean by that but that's when this
monster shows up right behind them now
in plain sight they move carefully and
towards the necklace and Annie gets a
little bit too happy about it and Yanks
the necklace and runs off like the wind
through the gorilla's legs it chases
them like a madman but that's when
Charlie knows his dog whimpering and
realizes that dog has never been trained
to carry two people before at this rate
they won't make it to the beach telling
Annie she's a cool chick he jumps off
and Kong runs past him Charlie then
tries to keep up with the chase but
stumbles into this trap he tries to get
out of it but then notices strange
people approaching him the island locals
they get ready to kill him but Charlie
begs them that he's just trying to get
home but this mysterious local warns him
that he'll suffer for what he did to
Kong back at Camp the group Waits
nervously and sees their worst nightmare
running past them in the distance
Captain notices that his son is nowhere
to be found and goes after him while
Mike overhears this Irene then gets
nervous and wants to go after Annie but
gets stopped by this dude who tells her
that she can't do anything right now
meanwhile cap goes deep into the jungle
but sure enough comes across another
monster this flesh-eating caterpillar it
Corners him and he gets ready to fight
this 12-foot beast and just then the
monster gets shot with a flare and runs
off and cap sees Mike standing behind
him and he passes out Captain notices
he's gotten worse and begs for him to
hold on back near the beach Annie and
dog finally reached the shores but the
gorilla jumps in front of them cornering
them and now he's royally pissed off she
throws the necklace at him waiting for
the sea monster to show up he goes to
pick it up and just then tentacles shoot
up from the ocean grabbing him and
pulling him into the ocean and the waves
Ripple back to the beach and sweep Annie
and the dog into the ocean with them
separating the two nearby the Monstrous
squid continues to drag Kong deeper into
the ocean okay [__] just got real bad
here look if I was them I would have
done the merciful Thing by killing our
best friend let me explain the group
here did everything wrong and how their
plan has turned out just proves this and
even if Mike was on the clock they can't
afford to mess up while this plan does
have some Merit assuming Kong could take
down this giant sea monster which wasn't
even certain which is why I would have
added to this plant a second contingency
and we should use our helpless dear old
friend here as a guinea pig it's noted
that Irene had access to call another
helicopter to them but the problem was
dealing with Captain squid face over
there this is why aside from luring Kong
to the monster before calling another
helicopter to save us I would have also
at the same time tried to move Mike to
another part of the island nearby then
I'm going to make all of us in the group
conspire against Mike this group is full
of survivalists and are likely carrying
spoons with them I would get as many
pairs of spoons that I could get from
them and cut the handles off and drill a
small hole at both ends and tie a long
enough string to them this would make a
makeshift Bachelor that is basically
designed to lure fish through sound in
the water then I'm gonna take Mike time
up and toss them onto a makeshift raft
with these bass lures and then push them
out into the sea and then with Annie
luring Kong to the squid we could have
kept the squid busy enough long enough
to escape the island on the new incoming
helicopter and then while on the way of
getting out of there we could have tried
to save Annie and I guess the dog I
guess they reached the bottom of the
ocean the squid chokes the life out of
Kong about to pass out he sees a sunken
boat nearby reaching out to it he grabs
it and slams it into the Squid's face
barely escaping and reaching the surface
coughing up blood Kong sees dogs
struggling to survive and Annie calling
out to him remembering his human
companion years ago he decides to save
dog and return him to Annie but that's
when he gets yanked back into the water
and sees his mortal enemy still alive
pissed off Kong grabs it and beats the
[__] out of it surely leaving it dead
this time around he climbs this rock and
pounds his chest as the reigning King of
the island and he sees his necklace
reached the shore and hands it out to
him that suddenly a tentacle shoots out
and attacks Kong the third time and he's
had enough and picks up the squid and
rips it in half and throws it right
towards Annie and the dog plunging into
the water a huge tsunami forms and head
straight for Annie she gets on dog and
they try to outrun it but he crashes
into them splitting them up again and
dragging Annie onto this rock cracking
her skull and making her black out she
suddenly wakes up in a strange roof
Irene enters and she asks where is her
dog she tries to calm her daughter down
and says she's been unconscious for two
weeks desperate she tries to leave this
room Yanks this door open but sees all
these humans around her she's confused
she runs to the window and pulls the
curtain and discovers that she's back in
Civilization there's no King Kong no dog
and no Charlie and if you don't want to
for your throws then like comment let us
know what you liked and of course didn't
like don't get check out the hot heavy
playlist down below